parfois tu n'étais toujours pas ce
que j'appellerais le danseur tu freines fort mais
tu ne fais pas vraiment partie de la culture
ouais les gens ressentent le besoin de me le
rappeler aussi souvent que possible
ouais ma chambre à coucher maintenant ne peut pas
revenir et  la première chose que je vois c'est que tu
danses dans le club comme avant je
vis je pense que tu es vraiment talentueux tu
vas le faire c'est juste une audition
qui ne danse pas c'est un truc quand je
te regarde danser je préfère tourner ou
quoi que ce soit  c'est ce que tu fais là-haut jamais
regardé ce sont toutes des idées que tu viens de
marier tu seras tellement plus heureux
ils sont mieux que cet endroit
hé y avait-il un Luka ou quelque chose qui
est venu je le veux dans le spectacle cette
femme votre  la nouvelle meilleure amie glisse chez les
stagiaires sur la façon dont vous
devriez tous vous rencontrer l'aime bien j'ai menti je ne lui fais pas
confiance cuca je suis désolé mais arrête de
rêver
si jamais tu me vois venir avec moi sortir
ici aucun signe de tout ce que j'étais  ça va
être long dur et douloureux pas d'excuses tu
échoues il y en a dix de plus derrière  tu as
quelque chose que tu veux ajouter ne crains pas j'ai
[Music]
parlé au réseau aujourd'hui et il
semble que nous allons reprendre l'émission
nous allons commencer tu as quelque chose de
spécial d'accord ne le laisse pas passer  par
[Music]
peu importe ce que disent les ennemis